due to our recent developments in the in
this this week in the candidate
tournaments I have decided to dedicate
our games for today for the one and only
Fabiana Khurana good job Bobby and we
are going to see how this amazing player
used his pawn pawns to to finish his
matches and as well how how he beat
other players and we really
congratulations to two Fabiano well done
now before before I begin this lecture
today I would like to ask us a small
question which nobody else has ever
asked before
no grandmaster no the International
master no no coach and I would like to
ask this question to to our viewers at
home as well to our viewers here in the
st. Louis chess club and the question is
what amount would you put or what amount
of value of dollar amount would you put
on touching a piece and just for example
today because we have our lecture about
pawns let's say I have a Bible pawn in
my hand and just touching the pawn how
much can it cost you what I said touch I
say just touch so if we have a pawn here
if you guys can talk me upon I can show
you what special effects I have a pawn
here that's all what I'm doing I'm just
touching with the tip of my finger
doesn't even it doesn't even matter
which finger touching go do this so how
much would it cost you what do you guys
think and today I'm going to show you
I'm actually going to show you that
attach of a pawn can be worth half a
million dollars five hundred thousand
dollars well think about it I mean some
some people if somebody wins $500,000
for them it's for some people it's a you
know it's the whole amount of money
you're making in a lifetime maybe you
know maybe it's maybe it's enough for
two lifetimes so just you know just
small touch over piece that can be the
difference so let me prove it to you
today let's look at the last game that
was played between Alexander Grichuk and
Fabiana Khurana in our last game in the
candidates tournament which just
happened in Berlin okay so as everybody
knows Fabiano was was leading 1/2 point
ahead a but after after him we had we
had kayaking and we also had my medium
so it's quite it was quite a very
difficult decision for him you know how
to play because he was playing Fabiana
was playing the black pieces and
kayaking was was playing with the white
pieces so and and he knew that he field
tie with them he is actually going to
lose the you know the championship and
by the way I think in the candidates
it's not about money as much as going to
the next step which is challenging the
world champion so it's it's a tough
position so how do you play with black I
mean are you going to be very aggressive
and are you going to try to sacrifice
lots of pieces you're going to play the
sharp opening to to to let you to have
the chances to win the game or are you
going to be playing solid because you're
still playing with black so it's a very
interesting you know very interesting
question and you know as for myself I've
had I've had the opportunity to be in
such a position myself and with black
and I and I chose the Sharpe way and
actually I lost the game because I was
sacrificing too many pieces and I lost
the championship but so Khurana chose
the other way around so let's see what
happens so we should start with this
movie for and Fabiano star would a5 we
just know that II five
it's probably one of the most you know
just one of the most solid responses
again c4
if you for example would play for for a
win you know try to look at some sharp
positions you would start with with the
sim of c5 and we have lots of Sicilian
defenses variations okay so if I was
played Knight to f3 and obviously we we
know that the main move here is a knight
going to c6 also very solid started
opening but at the same time wife has
many options here at Bishop c4 is one of
the recent trends that we have in chess
there should be five is most popular we
also have the Scotch but surprisingly to
everybody
a Fabiano actually decided to play
Knight to f6 and Knight of 6 this is
what we call the petrov some people call
it the russian defense and basically so
far it just looks like black is
copycatting from white so glacial hill
played not the main line the main line
for white is to take this pawn on e5 and
I think that the idea for for great joke
you know he did not have any chances for
first place at the time so Grichuk on
the other hand did want to create some
sharp play some some something very
imbalanced also there isn't why he
didn't play that in my opinion is
because just a few games before that a
quran was playing against Kramnik in
this affiliation and once he played the
six and night went back to f3 Knight
takes it to here coming it's a lot
playing before that the main line a
chronic fade the move Queen to e2 and
Queen 22 and then 27th and really fast
there the Queen the Queen's get
exchanged and something like this and in
this position Cohen was playing black it
looks completely equal but Kawana was
able to to beat cranek and
again you know what's the only
difference in this in this position and
the only difference in this position
schematically is this the pawn structure
so we can see that on the Queen side
white has those double pawns the C 2 and
the C 3 points I mean most of the
players would just say okay we just
equal I mean how can I make progress but
that's that's a that this game is just
gonna be for another lecture so in the
game itself great sugar decides to play
this more of a sharp line d4 and
obviously the idea of d4 is to try to
commit left to taking this this pawn on
d4 because once black takes this pawn on
d4 white has a very good move e5 it's
kind of an intermediate move I don't
want to take on on default immediately
but I want to attack our Knight on on on
f6 the night will go to e4 and the idea
is that now white will take this power
the tempo d6 but d5 is usually being
played upon take some pissant Knight
example and 93 96 and Queen fo for
example so in this variation really
white white has some good chances
although the pawn structure remains the
same but White has the more active
pieces and he can even choose between
the short castle and and long castle so
after d4 Kawana decided to take on on e4
and again white here took only five the
other line for wife would be playing
something like Bishop to d3 and this
would probably transpose to one of the
main lines in the interpreter of defense
after 475 and maybe Knight takes e5 okay
so phone takes on politics on e5 is
played and now we need to play d5 so we
have two
to hold this this night on only four if
we don't play this move d5 it's only
very difficult white is gonna have the
space advantage and yeah we won't last
for long
so Knight B to d2 was played in the game
Knight takes D - we need to exchange
Bishop takes D - Bishop to e7 and Bishop
to d3
so here the other moves played some at
some other games between the pond hmm
deal of the in their game they played
they put the bishop on it - but to me it
looks like Bishop to d3 is good enough
so Bishop the team was played c5 black
is gaining some some space on the Queen
side see 396 and Castle okay so here is
an interesting moment I was watching
this game live when it went heaven here
from the from the center is chess club
and I know this I noticed that in the
game itself black played this move
Bishop to g4 which which looks which
makes sense I just developed my bishop
and I pinned the night and maybe I want
to take on e5 but you know if if Fabiana
would look to if there are results of
the other board words would be different
and let's say you know carry a king
would win already I'm in this point then
I think that Fabiana would have to try
to play for for a win himself and
there's a very interesting very risky
move here that they can try for example
this move g5 very logical to expose the
king this way but suddenly this is gonna
get lots of lots of imbalance lots of
technical opportunities the bishop can
just simply go to his six and the ideas
may be longer so of course this is super
risky but as we saw from other games in
the candidate tournaments such as Crimea
Iranian Kramnik when he when a place is
Rokinon g8 and then pushed g5
we see we see this more and more often
in top-level chess world players decide
not to castle and just started another
put the pawn storm okay so Bishop to g4
has been played rook to e1 defending the
pawn on e5 and Queen to d7 so again pay
attention that black still keeps white
in the dark as far as for his intentions
I don't know if like he's gonna Castle
short side I'm not sure if black is
going to cast a long side maybe I'm
going to keep my King in the center and
this is quite quite unusual because you
know as kids as beginner chess players
we always learn a castle castle castle
you have to defend your king but
basically this those ideas made many of
those ideas to keep the king in the
center as long as possible
we learned the norm from technology you
know the Angels showed us that it is
possible to keep to keep this the King
in the center of the world for longer
periods and keep our abundance guessing
so Queen d7 and now white play this move
h3 and now so this position has been
played before however now karana makes
is novelty if you can call it a novelty
any place is the bishop on h5 the other
the other game that that was played was
black played Bishop to f5 in this case
white simply you know took on took on
the five or white can also play this
move Queen to Queen to c2 and Queen
takes bishop takes on d3 Quinta's castle
rook a d1 queen is six was played and I
think that White has pretty good chances
after all those must have been made
because without the white the light
square bishop this this pawn here on d5
is gonna be under attack all the time
so in the game fabbi decided to keep the
bishops on the board by playing Bishop
to h5 and now why played this move
Bishop to her for just just supporting
this this pawn on e5 and also kind of
promotes the connection between the
Queen and the bishop in this in this
position
Fabiana played this move Queen to e6
kind of a strange rule why do we need
the Queen here only six so let's think
about well again black doesn't really
know where he well she should Castle yet
maybe long maybe short if it tries to
Castle short sometimes White has all
those kind of tricks with Bishop takes
h7 and creating you know this is the gig
gift sacrifice blacken can make another
waiting rule for example h6 which will
prevent white from taking on h7 and also
prevent Knight to g5 however this move
pawn to h6 is actually a very great
mistake and so try for our viewers
online and our member service centers
chess club try to figure out why is this
move h6 is so bad how would white punish
black correct very good yeah so the
transposition of moves so in this case
white will play g4 attacking our bishop
on h5 you can see pay attention that
these kinds of tricks will not work
because our Bishop can simply go to to
GT and defend itself and the bishop goes
to to g6 then now we have this move g6
damn now it's hitting everything not
just the Queen the pawn and our bishop
he is under attack so we have to be very
careful when we when we don't castle so
I assume this was caranas population
still because they played the opening
stage pretty fast
you know they have to know though those
moves yes there's a question g5g for so
for black yeah so right now g5 just for
okay so if I take that's interesting
let's see this yeah I would say I would
say this is possible then why who maybe
go back with the bishop to to GT and now
we definitely need to castle alongside
yeah maybe maybe this was also possible
but again this is super risky okay so
this is why I played Queen e6 in the
game
83 and you know Wieck is stopping to
propel his expansion on the Queen side
and here's well Fabiana c is okay well
if I cast alongside I don't want to get
into those sharp positions where we have
opposite side castling and so he decides
just a casual short before was has been
played and now you played h6 so again
this move is very important because
basically this allows any kind of
tactical opportunities for for white so
h6 Bishop to g3 and BC so this position
is is quite equal we have some kind of
an imbalance in the pawn structure but
overall as put the equal position so
what what to do you what to do here with
white let's say fuel playing he was
white Alec standard-issue find a very
tactical solution to the problem the
problem was is that he he wasted lots of
time so I think just flew the fleet the
board and let's say you're playing as
the white pieces
yeah so that deaf penis is pretty
annoying right and that that's the whole
problem in the position so Glee shook
find a very tactical tactical option
here and he played in the game this move
Knight to d4 so your idea is correct you
want to get the Queen out not to be
three because on b3 black and fall with
c4 maybe but I think maybe he could have
played Queen c2 and now black needs to
face this this idea that first of all we
cannot take you on on f3 because of ya
Bishop f5 and the Queen get gets
captured and always all we take the
bishop first and with them and then we
have all kinds of stress with Bishop a5
and f4 so in this position black would
have to play something like Bishop g6
and in this case we can either take the
bishop and all play okay a d1
immediately or plate afterwards and I
think keeping the keeping the the Queens
on the board would allow District two to
have mode again more chances in the game
because the problem was is that you know
it's it's also all about time management
and in this position he played this
brave move Knight to d4 attacking the
King on on e6 and you know sacrificing
our Queen here obviously this move 924
will require lots of calculations and
well why is that because black has many
candidate moves right that can take this
night with a pawn you can take it to the
night you can take the Queen and maybe
he can move the Queen so it requires
lots of effort and then time to
calculate all of that and I also don't
think that it was the right decision for
him to go to an endgame you know because
eventually if we exchange all the pieces
you might be safer but again white is
the one who is playing for a win
okay so knight Knight to d4 has been
played
black needs to take the queen Knight
takes Queen context and rook a takes on
d1 well on the other hand white on you
know form for white perspective white
got the to Bishop advantage so that's
something right I mean the to Bishop
advantage decides many time many many
games okay so let's see how is your end
game play and so black to move what to
do here with black we need a plan
White has those two bishops White has
seemingly he has the better rooks as
well but so so how to play next okay so
you're saying c4 why is that what would
you push up on okay so you want to lock
down the position okay anybody else so
right now what happened is what we call
a transformation of a position we
basically transform from one stage of
the game to another so we have three
stages of the game we have the opening
of the middle game in the endgame so
every time that we do such a
transformation we really I always tell
my students you know take your time you
know take take at least five minutes and
then think about if you have the time
obviously but because that's that's well
you have to replan reassess the position
so we went from a middle game to kind of
an end game and and gameplay is much
much different i mean we know that for
example we can use a king an endgame so
what do we need to play king of seven
here immediately
well probably now not yet try because
there's still lots of pieces on the
board so the question becomes you know
what kind of a position to be what do we
want to open up the position do we want
to take on before or play five to open
this up
do we want do do we want to lock the
position with c4 so how do we how do we
manage how do we assess the put the
position
that's the difficult part so so first of
all let's let's answer a question number
one we do we want to open up the
position or do we want to close it close
open open okay so why why open it white
clothes yeah okay so you're saying let's
put the rookie on d8 and stop pushing
those bones all right yes okay so you're
saying white has the two bishops and
that's why we need to close the position
because we need to close the bishops
okay make sense anybody else so yeah so
we have the two views and again this is
that's the difference right that's the
difference of a position we have you
know we dope all it has the two bishops
and we know that the two bishops they
really like open positions where when
what are the Knights like well close
positions so I think this is why a
Kawana chose to to play more of a a
closed position for example if I play
rook 88 which was suggested probably
immediately white can play something
like Bishop to b5 and Noah can annoy us
and maybe you can put the rook here on
the tool to attack this this pawn so he
eventually he did play that that plan by
the way he just he just said he needs
some time to rearrange his pieces so c4
this is how we close it and so why is he
for you know as somebody said that here
in the audience we want to put our pawns
on light squares why is that because our
Bishop is dark okay we always want to
put our points on the opposite side on
the opposite color of our Bishop because
then our Bishop is going to be much much
more open so c4 has been played Bishop C
to b5 why tries to open up the position
with a 4 and we say
a six there was another more risky
option here instead of a six black could
also play a five and the idea is that if
Y takes on here will be five then we can
even sacrifice all night pawn takes pawn
takes and yeah Black has three pass
bones White has one pass bone it's
almost like a chaos here on the board I
mean yeah I don't even know who's better
it looks scary for both sides and it's
pretty much playing for three results
over here so again and you know Fabiano
takes the more conservative approach and
it just plays a six let's let's see what
happens by what I need to risk it f3
must be has been has been played okay so
in this position again black needs
needed to - to the side again black
could have sacrificed this night so for
example again night X before and and go
to this end game but instead Fabiana
just played Bishop to g5 improving his
bishop so far makes make sense
Bishop to f2 at the bishop here on on GT
really did not do much I mean just
defending this this pawn on only five so
why decides to transfer the bishop
somewhere somewhere closer somehow more
active so Bishop to f2 has been played
and Bishop f4 attacking this this pawn
on d5
Bishop c5 white puts his Bishop Hill
with a temple and as the gentleman here
suggested there who goes on D on d8
because in the future
black will try to open up the position
with d4 so look f d8 and Bishop to d6
okay so the bishop came here behind
enemy lines but he's doing pretty good
job is blocking the Darach here on d8
and he's defending this pawn he's taking
away some some other good squares so
from black so putting good Bishop here
on d6 okay so black to black to move
here what to do next
yeah and so in the game he played this
this idea bishop GT so what's the
purpose of the subject or exactly very
good so this was this was the this was
the correct move Bishop g3 and the idea
is not just to attack the rook here
the idea was to restrict the White King
from coming to F 2 and H 2 and for
example if black would do anything else
and let's say I play King of 7 then
really it will give white some some
chances after king of 2 then is lapu g3
it'll push f4 so this restriction move
the bishop to g3 this kind of an output
for the bishop is really really
important in the game so Bishop g3
rookie 2 and now black gets on space g5
king f1 king f7
now Bishop to to see 137 attacking
attacking this this rook rook e8 has
been played and Bishop to d6 so why this
going backwards and forward but the
bishop so how do we call it yeah we call
it a loss of tempo but in table chess it
just players they call it kind of an
unofficial draw fir you know that
usually in a chess game you know you're
allowed to offer draw in table chair but
in top chess games when when you just
playing is your livelihood when you
offer somebody a draw and it can be seen
as an act of witness because when you
offer the job to somebody something is
wrong it you don't the other don't see
how to win a positional maybe you feel
bad or stuff like that
so you know if you offer a draw it's
it's kind of you're making yourself the
you know very vulnerable to the opponent
and if he declines it to you you feel
like well you know you have to somehow
you're in the worst position even if
you'd if you're not so instead what tap
just just players doing the world is
that they're trying to repeat moves in
this way you know you'd only be a draw
for but you're just repeating moves and
for example if karana would play the
route d8 they'll continue to repeat the
moves well then a draw be signed so so
this is pretty much how they offer a job
okay well what would be the best way to
I guess to decline that draw not only
not to play rook to d8 but what what
other move can we play so black to move
broke on
yeah so you can play at the roof to a
seven yeah or in the game he played rook
a to c8 that that's a that's a pretty
pretty impressive decline right I mean
okay if you wanna repeat moves go ahead
play Bishop c7 that's fine with me but I
cannot promise you that I'm gonna put
clay rookie Adel next move you know so
so so Brooke - that's that's a pretty
bold statement so Ruth Ruth to c8 has
been played rook a one okay so the only
chance that wife has in this position is
really everything has to do with the a
file there is nothing else he can do
I mean look at all those pawns here this
pawn structure is everything is just
fixed and locked no f4 no h4 is possible
and this is really why black gets this
minor minor advantage I would say we
cannot see it but it's the potential for
creating a passport it's all about the
past bones here so here white will never
be able to get a passport unless
something some miracle happens black
because black fix fixes those points
over here on the other hand this pawn
structure at some point we can push d4
and thus creating the the sepal and
becoming a passport so why decides to
put his rook on the a file which we just
think was was a good move rook e to d8
black comes back now
okay so what to do here with white
some so you need to pay for with white
yeah we can take them b5 and if black
takes now to check on a 7 but white can
play rook a 6 now what is the problem in
this in this in this idea ok 6 it looks
like we're activating a rook it's good
they're going forward but there is a
minor problem yeah black and other play
d4 maybe yes there's another one that's
correct
so what's the weakness of this move rook
a 1 now ok 6 it weakens the first the
back rank so now black can play ok 8 and
if we take the knight oops it's amazing
too
only if I give out the bishop so in this
case white would have to take the rook
because we don't have a backup rook we
can't just do this move I wish that the
row can jump over pieces but you can't
yet and if it takes the rook the rook
takes and suddenly black is the one with
the control of the a file if that can
get the control all over the a file
that's I mean that you can't even stop
ok a 1 so that's pretty bad so you can
see how this position is pretty
difficult for white to play even though
I mean it doesn't look that bad I mean
white is almost has more space he has
the two bishops so taking on b5 is not
an option I think that in the game
what Grisha played was probably one of
the moves that stubberd his his defeat
he played this move Bishop to b1 and I
always say to my students if you don't
have to go backwards don't do it I mean
the the bishop to be 1 does not give you
anything you know the bishop on c2 is
doing a good job in defending the a 4
square so if I were him I would you know
if you don't have plan well stick to
stick to the plan that you had before
which was repeating the moves so I will
if I were him I would just play route d1
and just go back and say well you know
maybe I don't have a plan but show me
yours and especially the the rook is
gonna come here to prevent this move d4
so roof to be one was kind of a waiting
move that swipe did and now black played
roof to d7 and now again so what what to
do he would wise so black just played
this move rook to d7 let's look at this
position and saying the interesting
person I think that probably here wiper
the decisive move decisive mistake it
doesn't look like a decisive mistake but
he's made another waiting move he played
this move rook to a3 and we don't see it
right now but it's actually probably do
the move that lost the game but what to
do here instead there's there's a
different plan
always ask yourself what is change in
the position so black just played this
move rook to d7 even though the move the
move doesn't look like much it just
looks like a waiting move every move has
an advantage and a disadvantage and you
need to figure out what's the
disadvantage in that wolf yeah but if I
play if so the bishop on g2 is super
annoying right there's no doubt about
that
but if we play Bishop c5 I'm just gonna
take on e5 with the bishop and then
let's say the bishop is gonna take here
then I've got a given C 3 so and then
before it's gonna be like a domino
effect yes please
exactly
exactly very good job so now when the
rook is here on d7 we don't have this
double pole double Roxon on day 8 okay
so now white can take you on b5 and play
this move rook a six now I can activate
my rock now black cannot allow you to to
keep the stroke on a6 otherwise soon I'm
gonna be in the other oak and then you
know get it get in it ain't get in there
and so black has to play for example
Brooke a7 we need to exchange the rooks
take we have to exchange take Luke a 296
and bring the other okay in now although
in this variation we are sacrificing
upon so for example Knight takes on e5
well we obviously cannot take with a
bishop right everybody can see why we
can take with a bishop exactly rocks e6
you guys are sharp today so 9 takes
Knight takes d5 it looks like we just
lost the pawn but hey look at our pieces
I mean suddenly our Bishop is attacking
not defending this Bishop is attacking
that defending district is attacking not
defending so for example white can
simply play here ok 7 check King has to
go
yep you cannot go up because of Bishop
e7 yeah that's that's that's pretty
dangerous so he has to go well up this
way I guess came to g8 and now we can
for some of check on h7 and now Mitchell
goes back to c2 and yes we are upon down
but hey I mean he cannot move his knight
careful of his bishop his room doesn't
have any good spots and so this is what
we go but we got now we got this
compensation what we call and I actually
would prefer her to be white suddenly so
this was this was the opportunity that
white kind of lost in the game and he
could take on on d5 but instead he
played this move rook to a3 a very a
very bad move okay so black black to
move what do we do now it is the time
it's the d-day let the invasion begin d4
all forces ahead now the problem is
suddenly those two rooks which which
were on the usually on the first rank
suddenly they are not there so now he
white will have to cope with all those
threats with with some eight so d4 was
played a takes b-58 ax b5 now white
cannot allow black to play this move d3
so that's going to be devastating so it
takes on d4 Knight takes on d4 attacking
the rook rook a - E - a - okay so still
yeah I mean at least so black got up got
this pawn this passed pawn on c4 but
white is planning to come and visit us
here on the on the back ranks black to
move what to do next
Roxy 696 and what's the idea right
that's correct so now we want to focus
on the witnesses b4 + e5 right now that
defendant by the bishop but the bishop
really cannot defend everybody
it's a bishop it's not a Superman so but
Knight going back to c6 city was also
was also possible in this position we
played by black but again it will
require more calculation so again a
Khurana is taking the safer route and
just plays 96 Bishop b4 was played
because we cannot defend it you cannot
defend this pawn for example if rookie -
then we can simply take the pawn on e5
taking the roof to d1 oopsie
okay so why decides to sacrifice the
spawn I guess it's if you can call the
sacrifice Bishop three four bishop takes
on e5 the hill it's kind of a strange
but White has to choose between which
who to take the knight or the bishop in
the game a group took to the night I
think maybe they taking the bishop would
give him a slight more chances do to
take take Andrew k5 and now you know at
least his you stop to annoy a black and
at least I have a bishop for for that
for that lost pawn and bishops are much
better in the end game is as you can see
this this Bishop is not bad at all
covering autos this is actually pretty
much the most optimal square for the
bishop in a in a chess game so instead
gracious decided to take the night
instead and rook takes on d6 has been
played and Bishop takes on b5 yeah so
why together he got his pawn back but
now it allowed black to push his pawn
because I actually I'm in the one very
second
yeah so rook to d1 check has been played
King to rook to g1 came to e3 roof to be
one roof to be one has been played
attacking the deponent before and okay
seven check and King to f6 so this is
this is by the way move number forty so
they made a time control and they get
they got the extra time Bishop d7 now
Bishop f4 into e2 rock to the eighth and
white played rook to c2 okay so black to
move so what do we do here do we take
this pawn before we don't think this
pawn before
yeah well it's black to move do we so
black Tomas of white to play the rook to
c2 so don't we take the put this pawn
before we don't take it
oh it's poisoned we can take it but
there is something better
they can't remember I think I think it's
the same I think it's the same thing
karana thought to himself I can take the
pawn but I think there's something
better I just can't remember why
preparation this move number 41 you know
something yeah rooks it is definitely
possible and the question in those kind
of positions if you if you can if you
can see we have the opposite color
bishops we have those the rooks but do
we want to exchange all the rows and the
answer is probably no if we exchange all
the rocks we're going to get to a bright
choice endgame so they have to be very
very careful when we when we exchanged
those strokes so at least you have to
keep one of them so maybe Roxy one is
not draw immediately but it definitely
in my opinion helps black so in the game
Fabiana to de-spawn on on before
you know it's it's a passport we can
just snap it but the other way to think
about is that there's there are also
some weaknesses and the other witness on
g2 so the atom move that we actually
will look in here when we were watching
the show the live game and it's the
Chess Club was root 2 G 1 it's very
difficult to make such a decision too
during the game but here is the idea if
the King goes to f2 and defends the
point attack to the rook we can go rook
to d1 attacking the bishop on g7 from
both sides and he has to move the bishop
let's say and now we exchanged the rook
but the point is is that now we play c3
and then push push this is this this
point is unstoppable now if white tries
to play d4 black can play this very very
unique move subtle move rook to h1 and
the threat is to take this pawn and the
rook h2 and now if it takes this pawn on
c4 we can check and now rope to d2
so yeah so this was this was possible
but again Karadzic chooses the the
safest route just true takes him before
I mean this this this point on g2 is not
going anywhere so right now I'm just
playing a winning endgame where they put
a pawn up so Bishop to c6 has been
played c3 and the route to d7 so as we
said why this is the one who is trying
to exchange the ropes yes exactly so
under on this moment and the other games
were finished and kayaking so kayaking
Nvidia of the boat through and this this
you know this was a very interesting
question to see do you just draw you
know you if you offer a draw you're just
a pawn up there is no for example if I
just take this rook and I play rugby to
and you know I just exchange exchange
everything there is no way to lose this
I mean even if I give up the this point
and this point and I put this ball on h4
the there's simply a draw is just no not
nothing to do so the question was would
he would Fabiano you know awful a draw
or glittery draw and here I think we
also had a Skype call with Garry
Kasparov and other commentators here
everybody agreed that yeah sure you know
everybody would do it you know they did
the tournament is over and you're gonna
win clear first half point ahead and
yeah I mean what's what what's the point
well the point is that you can't you
can't lose any anyway so unless you
really really blunder and in this in
this point you decided just to keep keep
going that's a that's very impressive
so a please rook c8 keeping the ball
they get the rooks on the board
the bishop goes back and now h5 so the
idea is again we want to fix this this
weakness on on on g2 by playing h4 next
also gets it get gets rid of our
weakness because maybe wife can come
here to h7 attack this
so h5 has been played King to d3
rook to be too keen to e2h for rook to
d1 the King comes in
rook to a one route to d8 rook to d1 so
why this is simply waiting there's
nothing much white can do and just you
know just to pray for some kind of a
queen exchange Group D to be 8th route
to a one Bishop d2 I think that you know
objectively White is the one who is
spending much much more time in on every
move because you know every move can can
can lose the game and so why they're
spending much more time and for black is
just easy to make just random moves so
rope to a six seven play root D eight
locus is six rugby one King f2 has been
played rook a one Roxy for Rosie for
going back and forth
look before King e to King F for
and King to f2 so white this also it's
black to move in this position and if
you remember I opposed this question
just in the beginning of the video
how much pond touch can be wharton in
value in dollars let's say i just just
come to any chessboard and just touch
upon just slightly and at least from
from this game i will put it in $500,000
and a half a million dollars and why is
that what what happens if black touches
the wrong pawn if black played touches
this pawn on e6 just even slightly and
all the cameras are watching you can
just like go go back and it plays a five
you're losing one move and you just get
generated in one move and so you won't
win the first place you want to win the
first prize so you probably wouldn't
like place number four going form think
of the first prize was like 120
something thousand dollars so you're
gonna get to only like 80 or 70s to get
those fifty thousand dollars over there
but the worst worst part is that you
won't be playing in the candidates I'm
sorry in the World Championship and you
know the World Championship I think that
the prize fund is 750 for first place
and 500 for second place it was
sponsorship and you know the or the
glory so it's yeah I would say also
altogether is probably a million billion
dollars maybe millions of dollars so
this is how it just the touch of a pawn
can cost you millions of dollars so be
careful when you touch those pawns so so
king of two has been played so instead
Fabiano played rugby to be one route to
FA check now King to e5 Bishop d3 rook
to e1 check
King to f2 and now comes the final stage
well black for gamma plate this will
route 2 c1 basically forcing this rook
on c2 to make a decision hey which I
choose buddy which Ruka do you would you
like to would you prefer to take in this
case he why - can't be too
but even if he would you know if even if
it if it would take at the c1 rook and
this would end in a check king of
widening Bishop before and this again
this this pawn is very difficult to stop
so rook takes from B to C takes on B - I
want the Queen won't be one route to b8
start trying to stop him but he'll again
black and just make some some random
moves I mean obviously he makes progress
the overall idea for black is eventually
bringing the King here to g3 once I
bring them a king to GT and I start
stepping all those pawns I can get
another passport and this the game is
gonna be over and this is exactly what
he is doing he plays king of for route
to before E 5 now roof to b7 and King to
g3 and this is where black just wants to
take this pawn either this way or I can
bring my rook in here and again once I
snapped this one of the board that will
stamp this one of the board and once
this guy's keeps running that's gonna be
game over
so this is where a grecian decided to
you know to resign and Fabiana Kohana
became probably a candidate for the
world championship and we are going to
look forward to it in November in in
London so good job Bobby and good luck
good luck
[Music]